there's a woman who's gone totally viral
and she's just a random woman no one's
ever heard of her before she posts a lot
of content on social media so she
clearly wants to be a public person but
until this weekend she had been a
private person and I think it was Walsh
actually I think it was Matt who
discovered This Woman's Tick Tock and
made her go viral she's gone viral for
explaining how happy she is not to be
married and not to have children because
she gets to sleep in late and drink too
much and go to concerts and things like
that and she's going viral because while
her words say that she's very happy her
eyes and her demeanor and the tone of
her voice tell a different story
it's 10 45 a.m on a Saturday I'm 29 and
single and I don't have kids yet here's
what your Saturday morning looks like
when you're single at 29 and you don't
have a kid running around the house I
didn't rise from my bed until 10 15.
every time I thought I should probably
get up and do something I thought why
nobody's making me I'm not missing out
on anything I went to Beyonce last night
and I didn't get home until 1am and I
danced and drank my little heart out and
I didn't pay a babysitter to watch my
kids as I did that and I woke up a tad
hungover this morning which is probably
why I was in bed for so long and I was
just scrolling on my phone and I saw a
picture of shakshuka and I thought you
know it sounds really good maybe I'm
gonna learn how to make shakshuka today
this woman had my total sympathy a lot
of conservatives watched this and
reacted with scorn and derision she had
my total sympathy until she mentioned
shakshuka which is disgusting shakshuka
is this breakfast dish where you you
poach eggs in a spaghetti sauce and it's
just gross and poached eggs are fine I
like poached eggs and spaghetti sauce I
like very much of course and all sorts
of different dishes but you put those
two things together it's gross I like
veal salt in Boca I like green Jolly
Ranchers I don't want to put them
together so anyway that's where she
really started to lose me and and her
monologue went downhill from there
because I have no plans and I don't have
kids and I don't have a husband and I
don't have errands to run I can go to
the grocery store and learn how to make
shakshuka so that's on my agenda today
also on my agenda probably a re-watch of
some Real Housewives of New York I'm
also doing a re-watch of normal people
on Hulu which is really spicy and I
highly recommend weirdly I'm into this
documentary on Netflix about Blue Zone
countries so I've got a pretty stack day
anyway I say all this to say whenever
I'm hard on myself about why I'm not
married and I don't have kids and I
should be further along at 29 almost 30.
I wouldn't want to do anything else this
Saturday and I know that you can do all
these things when you have kids and
you're married and I understand but the
effortlessness and ease of my life just
kind of focusing on myself and the shack
shook I want to make or the Beyonce
concert I want to go to really pays off
when I'm hard on myself for not being
where Society tells me I should be in
life okay I have even putting the
shakshuka aside I have basically nothing
but sympathy for this woman because we
all have friends who are like this woman
some some Among Us listening right now
might be in the same spot which is
you got duped by Society our entire
culture told you to put off getting
married don't have kids just focus on
your career get an endless series of
degrees don't go to church don't believe
in anything above yourself life is about
nothing more than binging Netflix and
traveling around the world and having
fun experiences and going to brunch
that's what our culture tells people
from the age of
I don't know I guess from in the womb
all the way up until the Music Stops all
the way up until thing the brunches stop
being quite so tasty and the Real
Housewives reruns stop being so
interesting and the shakshuka stops
being so satisfying to make so I have
total sympathy for her and if she were
merely trying to say that while her eyes
and the tone of her voice and the Very
fact that she's pleading for attention
on social media shows that she's
obviously not totally happy and she does
wish that she were married and she does
wish she had kids but it hasn't happened
yet and so she's going to Bear her
difficulties with resignation until
things turn around
I wouldn't even bring it up the problem
here is that she is she is exalting the
very things that make people miserable
and it's because of a misunderstanding
of joy and a misunderstanding of Earthly
happiness which we'll get to in one
second you know they say that money
can't buy happiness but it can make you
secure to have the material things so
that you can pursue happiness and when
you want to be materially secure you
gotta check out Birch gold right now
text Knowles to 98 98 98 Vladimir Putin
called the US Dollars drop in dominance
objective and no objective and
irreversible
it's not a great Russian Brazil Russia
India China and South Africa formerly
have agreed to use local currencies in
trade instead of the US dollar as demand
for the dollar weakens the buying power
of the dollar weakens this is why Birch
gold is busier than ever investors and
Savers are looking to harness the power
of physical gold sheltered in attacks
sheltered Ira you can protect your IRA
or 401K by diversifying with gold from
Birch gold as the U.S dollar continues
to receive pressure from foreign
countries digital currency and central
banks arm yourself with information on
how to protect your savings learn if
gold is right for you too text Knowles
kwles to 98 98 98 they will send you a
free info kit on gold with an A plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
thousands of Abby customers and
countless five-star reviews I trust
Birch gold to help you diversify into
gold if a central bank digital currency
becomes a reality it will be nice to
have some gold to depend upon text
Knowles Canada W valleys to 98 98 98
George Bernard Shaw had a very good line
which is
that hell
is the place where you have nothing to
do but amuse yourself
George Bernard show is a socialist
atheist playwright and he was wrong
about a great many things but even when
he was wrong he would he would have
these piercing moments of insight in a
lot of his plays GK Chesterton the great
conservative Catholic author he was
friends with with Shaw and this this is
one of my favorite lines from shawa and
even the whole context of this line is
even better than the the single phrase
itself it comes from a scene called an
act of a of a play called Don Juan in
hell
and the play is Man and Superman and
a woman Anna says these devils are
mocking me I had better prey and the
statue consoling her says no no no my
child do not pray if you do you will
throw away the main advantage of this
place they're in hell
written over the gate here are the words
leave every hope behind ye who enter
which is a line shall borrowed from
Dante only think what a relief that is
for what is Hope a form of moral
responsibility here in Hell there is no
hope and consequently no Duty no work
nothing to be gained by praying nothing
to be lost by doing what you like hell
in short is a place where you have
nothing to do but amuse yourself at this
moment Don Juan sighs deeply
this is why people who retire
often don't live very long
some people have a great retirement but
the people I've noticed who have a great
retirement are the people who
find a purpose in retirement maybe the
purpose is to manage their family maybe
the purpose is to get involved
politically maybe the purpose is to take
up a new hobby or to join a group or to
write your Memoir or to investigate
genealogy or to play in the family
reunion but the people who just in
retirement go out and decide they're
gonna
hang out they often don't make it very
long they drink too much they get
depressed we all get depressed why
because happiness is not just receiving
passive Pleasures happiness our good
buddy Uncle Aristotle noted about 2400
years ago is excellent rational activity
in accordance with virtue so happiness
involves activity and it's activity done
very well and it's that activity that is
rational it's not totally irrational
activity like going out and I don't know
doing a bunch of drugs and making a
nuisance of yourself and worshiping
Idols in the desert is a rational
activity that is in accordance with
virtue
that's what's going to make us happy
what that woman is describing is broadly
true when you don't have kids you get to
wake up late you get to watch whatever
TV shows you want you get to make
shakshuka
if if that is something that one would
want to do you get to go out and drink
too much you get to go to the whatever
concert you want to go to and that will
make you depressed and this is why you
there are skyrocketing rates of
depression and anxiety it's no
coincidence that his marriage rates
plummet as childbirth rates plummet the
rates of anxiety and depression are
increasing because brunch is not
actually that fun it's not fun for a
long time so I don't mean to just scold
this woman I don't mean to mock her in
any way but it is
it is very dangerous for people who is a
self-defense mechanism or a coping
mechanism decide that they're going to
exalt the behaviors that make everybody
miserable that's a dangerous thing the
first step to fixing the problem and
individuals in society broadly have a
lot of problems right now the first step
is admitting that you have a problem and
in in this case the problem is that the
Beyonce concert and staying out too late
and drinking and staying in your bed all
day the and even eating shakshuka as as
your race on datra those are not the
activities of happy joyful people those
are the kind of things that depressants
do depressives drink too much and they
stay in bed all day and they're listless
and they kind of wander around and they
they're just not full of joy so if we
want to turn that around you've got to
put that bad advice aside stop coping
recognize there's a problem and then fix
it you can fix it man
or you don't need to stay in bed all day
and listen to Beyonce and eat chakshuka
boy what a great clip that was now make
sure that you ring the bell subscribe to
the Michael Knowles YouTube channel see
you next time